now
designing apis less data is more why is
this topic relevant to me
well i've been building apis for the
last seven years and i've seen a pattern
where developers like to expose more
data than is actually needed
i want to talk about avoiding overhead
when designing apis now what kind of
overhead am i talking about
i'm talking about building bloated
overly flexible apis with queries that
nobody asks for endpoints that nobody's
using generally unused functionality
extra fields relationships you know all
these things
that
probably nobody's using but you have to
maintain them
now what kind of apis am i going to be
talking about i'm going to be talking
about http based apis mostly because
that's what i work on and it could be
like rest apis json apis graphql etc but
really this api talk is technology
agnostic it's applicable for all kinds
of apis
now through this stock we are going to
be building a blogging platform
something similar to medium or dev2
now the blogging platform is going to be
fairly simple it's going to have authors
that can release posts and it's going to
have posts that can have comments
now
we're going i'm going to talk
through this talk to through two
principles for building apis
the first one being designing the
minimal api surface or how not to expose
over exposed data on your apis
and then designing from strict to loose
or how to avoid building extra
flexibility that nobody asked for
okay so for the first principle
designing the minimal api surface
generally i see a pattern where
developers try to be speculative about
what's going to be needed in the future
so they often over build their apis
now
i'm going to break this into three
patterns of a bloated surface that i
usually see first being
building redundant apis where they're in
the redundant fields then redundant
relationships and then redundant input
fields
so let's start off with the first one
don't expose redundant fields
now let's imagine we have a requirement
from our product manager
uh that says
that on our blogging platform we need to
show the author of the blog post
so now i took this screenshot from
medium
and let's imagine we on the back end
have some kind of an author's table that
has you know an id in a thought of an
author
a first name a last name an email and an
avatar url
and now
if you look at the screenshot or let's
imagine these are the designs that we
have
you can see we do have a need for an
avatar we do have a need for the first
name for the last name
we might need id for some kind of
client-side caching but we don't have an
email here at all
now let's imagine we have a friendly api
developer that's developing this api
now they might say well let's expose the
email somebody might find it useful in
the future you know why wouldn't we
expose the email field right away we're
going to spend more time exposing it
afterwards if we need it afterwards
right so we're saving time for the
business technically
now let's imagine this is some kind of a
schema descriptor that we have for api
and
we you know decided to expose all of
these fields including email field
now
let's imagine six months later for
privacy reasons we might need to stop
exposing the email field i'm not making
this up you know europe has gdpr laws
california has california privacy laws
and here you know in many of these
privacy laws you're not supposed to
expose
pai
data that
is technically not useful for the app
so
you know and the email here is really
not useful so we should start stop
exposing it now what happens now we're
going to go through a deprecation cycle
we need to you know mark a field as the
deprecated if our api schema descriptor
is actually allowed at or if it's a
version of the api maybe we need to
expose a new version so that seems like
a lot of work
and then we need to go to extreme
amounts of communication we need to send
out emails reach out to clients if we're
building a platform gets really hard we
gotta give a few months of lead time at
least
and
you know there's there could be like
uh
hundreds or thousands of consumers now
if it's a private api it might be a
smaller amount of clients but a lot of
communication
nevertheless
and then we might be breaking clients it
really depends on what kind of api do we
have if we have an api where
if uh
somebody asks for an author and they
immediately get all the fields back or
like you know if they if the api doesn't
have some kind of field selection or
sprite field sets
you have no idea whether you're breaking
clients or not
because they're going to get that
information until you remove that email
field
and then if you do have an api that has
some kind of field selection or sparse
field sets and you can you know
hopefully see
uh
through metrics and observability that
nobody's using that email field anymore
you might have some level of security
but you better have metrics on
observability to understand all of that
data
and then it's extreme amounts of
redundant cycles you got to do multiple
device you might need to deploy first to
staging and then you know test it out
there and then deploy it to prod and you
know previous to that you need to deploy
that it was deprecated
and then you know cross your fingers and
hope that everything goes well so it's
not just as easy as removing a few lines
of code like the technical aspect in
terms of coding is extremely easy there
you know anyone can do it anyone can go
in remove those lines and that's it and
ship it but actual operational stuff
that you have to do around it that's
that's the difficult part
okay
now
we first talked about not exposing
redundant relationships oh sorry
redundant fields let's talk about not
exposing redundant relationships
now
let's imagine we have a requirement
indicate whether a post was reviewed or
not
now let's imagine we
building out a new feature and that
might have like a group of reviewers
that is you know
that can review
uh
certain posts and then if
you know if this post is reviewed by
one reviewer
something like that we add like a green
check mark next to the title
uh just so
we know that it was reviewed
so now let's imagine this is our schema
descriptor for
for our post type or post resource and
it has a title and a body pretty easy
now
technically what our api developer might
think
would be to add just a reviewed boolean
field or something like that
now
but the friendly api developer actually
might go even further and might say well
you know let's expose the reviewer for
future use cases you know just just so
we don't have to add it later
so now the friendly api developer might
go a step further and actually you know
create a new reviewer resource or a type
in our api schema and expose it on the
post
now what happened now
well development costs are going we need
to do potentially some kind of batch or
eager loading because i'm you know
supposing that whatever
kind of storage
uh
you know the data is stored be sql no
sql or through multiple apis or
something like that it's probably not
stored in the same place so you you know
you have one location where you load
all the posts and then you have another
location where you load up all the
authors so you've got to do some kind of
batch or eager loading or something
along those lines
and uh
and then you gotta test it out because
you know what are you you're not gonna
ship this code without any tests i hope
and then
you know there's performance impacts if
again if
like our api has some kind of field
selection and then
users or clients can pick and choose
which fields they need
then maybe it's okay maybe it doesn't
have negative performance impacts but
if we don't then every time you load the
post you load the reviewers as well
then you know you're building out a
slower api from the start and nobody
actually asked you for that
and then what happens if like let's say
six months after
um you know our product managers decide
well you know what
we don't we won't have one reviewer
we'll have like multiple reviews we'll
have some kind of a collection of
reviewers so multiple people can review
this and we're actually gonna show them
now and so you know what are you
what are you gonna do like all of a
sudden
you know you got to deprecate this field
or
you you
have to do breaking changes
not really fun
so you know you got to go through a
deprecation cycle a lot of communication
emails slack messages again the same
drill
but then
there's one thing that we're not
utilizing here in the whole story
and that is delaying decisions
and that is adding later when we have
more knowledge is better so could you
imagine like if we didn't need it for
the first six months you know and that's
when we built it at the start of it
if we build it at the end of those six
months we would actually have more
knowledge about our system we would know
more we would know whether
you know we want to call it reviewer
maybe we want to call it authors as well
maybe we want to call it users maybe it
really doesn't matter
but we would have more knowledge at a
later point about the system that we're
building and it's good to delay a
decision like that because it isn't
impactful in terms of like the product
is still has the same set of features
and everything so like delaying those
kind of things really makes sense
and in general
it's easier to add in the future than it
is to remove i've been through this many
times where i was removing stuff that
nobody asked for you know and i
guarantee it's way easier to add in the
future than it is to remove sometimes
additions to the api can be done within
an hour
but
removals take a lot of time it's you
know rarely an hour it's usually weeks
or months of communication
okay so that's about exposing fields and
queryable resources
let's talk about
not exposing redundant input fields what
kind of input fields am i talking about
talking about the payload your api
accepts when you're mutating or changing
data and rest apis that would be your
api that gets you know your api
gets whenever a client initiates like a
post or a put request
or if you're building graphql apis that
would be whatever the arguments are to
your invitations so let's look at an
example we have a requirement that
readers need to be able to create and
update comments fairly simple right
now let's imagine we have some kind of
an input or you know payload that has a
post id
and uh
and and a body that it needs to receive
now the friendly api developer might say
let's have parity between the inputs so
you know if we have an update comment
let's have you know the same inputs that
we had on the create comment plus the id
so we can more easily reference it so
besides the id and the body of the
comment we also send out a post well all
that you need is an id and a body but
i've seen this developed many times
now i would say that the blogging
platform probably doesn't support common
transitions from one post to another
so there really is no reason to alter
that post lady so there really isn't no
any reason to actually expose it
so
this really doesn't make a lot of sense
and what are you gonna do on the back
end once once you get this post lady
like are you gonna verify if it's the
same and you're gonna let it pass
through and if it's different you're
gonna block it well you know that
doesn't make sense
so i would in general say try to avoid
dynamic data modeling you know sure the
comment have a post id
doesn't mean that we're able to update
it no you know these things do not have
to match you're supposed to build your
apps according to your business needs
and that business logic should be on the
server not on the client
now a great blog post that i would
recommend is graphql mutation design and
i'm a communication which is written by
mark from github or actually markzware
who's joining
us at netflix in a couple of weeks i
would definitely recommend this blog
post it is it is amazing and goes
uh more deep on this topic and anemic
designing with the dynamic design of
mutations
and in general i would say ambiguity
deteriorates developer experience you
know our clients might be confused
they might ask themselves you know what
happens if they send the same value what
happens if they send the different value
and then you know that might kick off
other conversations and now you're
you're just wasting time for everybody
and then lastly
yagni you ain't gonna need it
don't build it up if at some point you
do need it in the future it's an easy
additive change don't worry about it
okay cool
now
for the second principle that i want to
talk about today is strict to lose
so
i want to talk about it through two
paradigms as well and the first one
being avoiding extra flexibility and the
second one being breaks first
so avoiding extra flexibility
so when you're building apis you need to
be ready for extra flexibility in the
future but you don't need to be
extremely flexible now you need to scope
out what is needed for your clients
now
just give me a second
sorry
all the technical difficulties
okay now let's imagine we have a
requirement that the user needs to be
able to see comments on a post
pretty easy right
now let's imagine we have some kind of a
query or some kind of an end point that
or some kind of an end point that's
called comments
that you know receives a post id and you
know ideally it should be a required
argument
now the from the api developer might say
you know our clients might want to fetch
all comments in the future
so you know let's just make that post
the optional so you know they can send
it or not we don't care we're going to
support both what did we get with this
you know we got unneeded application
logic we need to handle both cases there
is opposed to eat and if there isn't
more code in general means more
maintenance so anytime you change some
commenting logic you need to reflect
that in both scenarios
what about like if you try to introduce
caching are you how i'm going to have
two different strategies for these and
then
more code means more tests you gotta
test both cases out right
so i would say on inputs you know or you
know
data that we receive from the client
it's easy to go from required to
optional but it's not easy to go the
other way around
strict to lose gives you more control it
gives the client less flexibility but
it's not the flexibility that they've
ever asked for that gives you more
flexibility in terms of changing
but lose the strict if you go from
optional to required is a breaking
change because you know certain amount
of clients might actually stop working
the ones that
might have not been sending that
uh value at all
okay and then the second part of the
second principle that i want to talk
about is breaks first or defensive
programming i want to talk about how you
should ensure that your api is not going
to get abused let's go with the same
example
let's imagine we have a requirement to
ability to fetch comments for a post
now the friendly api developer might say
you know let's just give them an array
of comments we don't need pagination or
a better version of this we don't need
pagination yet
now let's imagine we have this same kind
of comments query or endpoint and it
returns just an array of comments
the friendly api developer might you
know justify this with we won't have
more than five comments per post it's
all good
now you know six months later
they're supposed with hundreds of
comments so all of a sudden we do
need some kind of pagination otherwise
you know we
have kind of like a bad performance
experience
now the developer might say let's add
pagination well now what happens now we
let's say we
throw some kind of paginated comments
back really doesn't matter what it looks
like we're introducing a breaking change
and we're introducing a new query uh or
a new endpoint you know either one of
those either breaking change or a new
query or endpoint so nothing is really
that pleasurable about it
and you know the family api developer
might say work is done let's go home
that's it
now
you know what happens if a client sends
out a comment like this you know the
client might have been lazy to actually
do paginated requests so they might send
you know just give me the first thousand
records you know what happened well the
friendly api developer didn't add limits
imagination
i'd say generally adding pagination
limits of breaks of sorts uh from the
beginning makes a lot more sense so you
know you might
end up saying something like you know
requesting a thousand records exceeds
the first limit of 100 records so it's
super hard to add it retroactively but
super easy to adjust in the future you
can always put the number
to go up you can
let it go down
okay so
how to avoid these overheads
now i wanna
i would say adopt scheme of frizz design
you know figure out what is your domain
and for whom you're building your api
don't play guessing games don't couple
your apis to specific implementations
maybe today you have a relational
database that is backing some of this
data tomorrow it might be an api that
won't have the same fields and you might
bring yourself more trouble than
anything
and then talk to your clients involve
them early in the process figure out
what their needs are and then try to be
speculative
and then be responsive to your clients
requests as you're building out a
minimal schema that is not overloaded
you have to be responsive to feature
requests
there's always exceptions
to these rules you know some exceptions
that my you might see is like if you're
building a platform api there might be a
little bit of speculation here if you're
building a platform and trying to get
ahead of competitors to try to drive
user adoption but even then i would kind
of question how much this kind of
speculation is worth it
or if you have constraints due to a
release cycle and this has been an
interesting story that was told to me by
a co-worker that worked on apis that
were deployed on premises for their
clients so they would release these once
every six months and they would have to
do thousands of deployments every time
they release so if they miss the field
that a client might need they would have
to repeat the same redeployments which
would be very costly this is very unique
and probably most of us are not in this
situation
now in conclusion what i want to say
is that redundant work slows down
progress on important features you might
be able to spend your time more wisely
by improving your api documentation
improving slow queries etc exposing too
much data can be highly unproductive you
know there is a saying the road to hell
is paid with good intentions even though
we might think we're doing something
good for our api clients and being a
good partner
speculatively building apis
is well intended but with a negative
result
so
thank you all
this is my twitter handle if you want to
talk more about this topic let's talk
afterwards or reach out to me on twitter
and as i said i work as a senior
software engineer at netflix we have a
bunch of openings if you're ever
interested in building apis at netflix
reach out to me and let's talk